welcome back to the Rich Eisen Choka
have been fortunate to evolve met this
man since I moved out to Los Angeles
about 16 years ago and in such great
films that we all know about a few good
men usual suspects casino grumpy old men
grumpier old men and so much and so on
and so forth and now he is in a dynamite
television show called the marvelous
mrs. Mazal he is part of the ensemble
cast that won the SAG Award last year
just got nominated for another one this
year it's available for streaming on
Amazon Prime video good to see you Kevin
Pollak yes rich we must have met at a
poker table right yes it hank azaria
yeah that absolutely happened yeah and I
said at the top of this hour I don't
know if you heard I did it's very it's
true so I'll say it I've never heard it
put that way we felt it each other yeah
each other yeah and that's fun when it
happens instead of you watching or
listening get subpoenaed because of this
comment I feel stand witness it has it
has in fact you don't like it though you
particularly don't like it not like it
nobody likes it who likes it nobody
likes I've gone on to fell Daniel
Negreanu at the feature table on camera
room during the World Series of Poker
Main Event how did he take it he took it
well because he's such a pro it took a
much better than you remember me taking
him yeah how long did you last this year
so this year I was short stacked a small
amount of chips could be the name of a
book of mine joke stacked uh-hmm
it's very difficult to never get a stack
of chips that you have some any sort of
movement of momentum yes so you start
with 60,000 and chips
I was always between 85 and 45 it could
not get anything going beyond that and
at a certain point by day two you have
to start shoving all in whether you want
to or not so to be aggressive you got to
be selective with your moments I ended
up being 17 and no with my short stack
shoved over for days until I became of
course seventeen and one but to go 17 to
know what a run well when I had my
serious deep run 2012 out of six to
eight hundred players I finished the
134th yeah where you can see the last 14
tables yes that's bizarre you know I
probably shoved all in six times the
entire tournament
this seventy nano thing was just because
of the short stack issue so to make it
to day four and make the money late day
three yeah was great it was really great
so you know the number wasn't as
impressive 986 but the field this year
was almost nine thousand yeah I mean
like hey you know no one's gonna be
having walking around with foam fingers
I'm 986 but yeah when there's nine
thousand to start exactly you're in the
final ten just a cache which means I've
cashed two out of six right batting 333
I think I'm first round first of course
your first ballot my first no doubt and
and and right now you're wearing your
San Francisco 49er lid and sure so the
four and twelve team from last year you
may remember yes now they are flat out
tied for the best fired up yeah and big
weekend by the way not only finally not
missing a field goal which is the reason
if I may we only have two losses yes but
to make that field goal in the final
seconds and deal to drive back all the
way when in under a minute in New
Orleans in New Orleans it was an
extraordinary game then as my brother
and I are texting each other we've never
rooted for the Rams but for the Rams
within the Seattle that's allowing us to
have this better advantage yeah looking
down the by the end of the date so deep
what did you grow up in I saw John
Brodie that's how old I am
at a playoff game losing to Dallas which
is the first reason I hated that team
well I mean that all is what you know
why the catch was obviously the catch
was so big for many reasons but the fact
that it was finally against Dallas I
mean you're you're you're giving the
history of the yep animus between John
Brodie and and if I'm a the Messiah Joe
Montana yes um we I suffered through not
only DeBerg I mean Plunkett was a
quarterback at one point you know we had
very long
right go of it and then and then and
then the magic happened with Bill Walsh
in in the whole bit and so you were the
stick right I mean yes yes yeah yeah I
remember walking down the center of a
very very busy street yeah
in full traffic in San Francisco
high-fiving people going in both
directions after the first Super Bowl
victory yeah I know those moments are
just stay with you forever right like
you mentioned Bumgarner coming in fourth
inning in Game seven after very little
rest and taking it through the end right
all the way down to the last pitch you
know if you remember there's a runner on
third and anything was possible yes
indeed against the Kansas City Royals
yeah so if he plays our friends in
Kansas City if he plays for the Dodgers
it'll be one of the signs of the
Apocalypse for sure without question
without hesitation you look for
different horsemen and stuff like yeah
yes right yeah so it's possible I
understand that capitalism has basically
destroyed all professional sports so why
not my heart kevin pollak you're on the
Rich Eisen show alright let's get into
this man yes let's get into all of this
good stuff sure from your from your
career when did a few good men come
across your desk you're so I was doing a
six-week summer series for CBS yes that
no one would ultimately watch because in
the summer in 1991 it was all reruns
there was no real programming in the
summer so people just kind of went away
yeah but it was created by Rob Reiner
and Christopher Guest and it was a
ridiculous opportunity for me and so I'm
having lunch every day with Rob working
on that and one day he says you know my
next film was a very successful Broadway
play it's called a few good men and I've
got Tom Cruise I think I'm gonna get
Nicholson there's a part of Tom's
cocouncil that you're kind of perfect
for I have an offer out to Jason
Alexander
if Seinfeld gets picked up for season
two he won't be available Castle Rock
Rob's company right also it's not a
Seinfeld right so he said it's time for
gets picked up which was a big question
mark because it was on Friday nights
that only aired four episodes it was a
big
chances were this thing was going away
and I my prayers along with Jason
Alexander's prayers amounted to his
career doing very well and me getting a
few good men and getting a little busy
in the 90s because of it right yeah so
that's how you got so that's it that's
ultimately how it happened yeah all
right so now we've had Rob Reiner has
been here before out and I told you
before we've had him Kevin Bacon in Noah
Wyle hmm all tell they're from their
perspective right the final scene of
Jack Nicholson you want me on that wall
you need me on that wall that you can't
handle the truth etc the Colonel jessep
soliloquy yes that you have an
interesting well so well if I had a
nickel for every time someone a fan of
that movie which there are a lot of
let's face it it's on every 11 minutes
it's a remote drop
it's a remote drop like no matter where
you are right in the film right it's
like that for me it's that the fugitive
isn't that good fella's oh yes where no
matter where you are it's like oh god
two hours to go I don't care I'm just
dropping them yeah the remote yeah yes
correct and Casino I was fortunately
involved in another movie that for some
people is that that's a similar thing or
suspects those three but a few good men
you know I've been doing personating
Nicholson my whole stand it back how I
started hmm so to just be around him was
bizarre and surreal and my character has
no no dialogue with him we shake hands
when we meet in his office in the
beginning of the movie so what time
against the courtroom and he singles me
out who's gonna do with you you
lieutenant Weinberg what so clearly
Aaron Sorkin the writer yeah it's a very
young pup at that point in his career to
only done the Broadway play that he
wrote wanted everyone to know that
Jessup was also anti-semitic yeah
there's no other reason to point out you
lieutenant Weinberg who's gonna do it
you Tom Cruise are you gonna do it did
you are you gonna stand a pose
so if I had a nickel for every time
someone on the street is pointed that
out and they also
as a question they'll say Kevin I gotta
ask I'm so sorry maybe you get this a
lot when he says who's gonna do it you
you lieutenant Weinberg why is he
picking you out you've done nothing to
upset the man other than walking across
the desert for 40 years so so when it
came to Nicholson on the stand doing a
soliloquy I'm watching him an oath Rob
said but Jack shot for 10 days speak out
of turn why not he made 5 million for 10
days half a million dollars a day and I
asked him when you make half a million
dollars a day do you hit the snooze
alarm clock so he only had five days in
the courtroom that's it to shoot
everything and at the end of the five
days I'm sure Rob explained they weren't
quite done with Jack but so Rob had to
go to Jack and say I can't afford to pay
to come back another day but if you out
of the goodness of your heart come back
for just a couple more shots I'll get
you up by noon by 12 noon I promise
right no matter where we are you're
you're wherever you need Robby I'm here
so after watching him do this this
speech yeah for so many days and I'm
saying it to my rear view mirror on the
drive home you know because it's so
brilliantly written my goodness when
that 12 noon time came Jack was sitted
like this looking at the judge where you
are doing Jack was doing at that point
off camera line so the camera was over
Jack right onto the judge right and so
Rob said cut that's a wrap on Jack
Nichols and everyone goes you know
bananas and lots of hugs and kisses and
I quietly went over to Rob and said look
I've got this damn thing memorized and
if it's helpful at all to AJ the actor
who played the judge I'm happy to sit on
the stand and and do the off-camera
lines for him not for a goof not to
entertain my crew but and again only if
it's helpful to him to have someone do
that right I'll do it as Jack is what
I'm saying
and so the actor playing the judge loved
the idea and so we did it and yes after
I finished the first one the 150 or
whatever crew member did break into
ridiculous applause which was not the
intent not asleep appreciated your being
your your profession yeah it was
appreciated I'm not gonna lie to you I
might have taken about but I was there
for that actor and so the biggest
compliment was back then the directors
would have to go to for you kids out
there what was called dailies they would
process the film yes they used film and
two days later the director could look
at those scenes so Rob came back after
going to dailies a couple days later and
said it took me four cuz I was
off-camera again as was Jack so we went
from Jack right into me and he said it
took four takes before I realized it was
no longer Jack and I don't know that
there's a better cop no I'm not at all
no did you did you lay into the
lieutenant Weinberg line you know what I
wanted to be there for the other actor I
did not put a little extra spin on it it
was already there I mean the Hebrew I
just it's you know the question really
right I mean but the other the other
three who have preceded you from the
film in that guest chair all said that
when Jack was doing it off camera he
didn't skip a beat he never same thing
every single four five days he never
missed a syllable I mean I mean I talked
about in my standing back how I'd never
seen an actor turn it on and off right
as easily as he could because when he
when when Rob Reiner yelled action he
was letter-perfect never misses Silla
but when Rob said cut hmm Jack looked
like he'd been stoned for three days I'd
never seen anything like it
right just he'd stand up and he was so
good garius and goofy right which is
also not what I expected really I
thought he'd be aloof you know someone
who at that point even in 92 he'd been
cool too five generations somehow you
know right or so it seemed and I just
pictured him oh there's Jack over there
and you know look at him don't talk to
him and but he was the most approachable
gregarious of any
giant iconic movie star I've ever worked
kevin pollak you're on the Rich Eisen
show and in terms of casino yeah of all
the people that I would want to ask you
about it has to be ripped on Rickles
hands down right yeah because watching
him rip into De Niro on set in the
middle of a take there's no greater joy
really I think I've seen that on on
Twitter right isn't it what do you do he
just ripped on him in the middle of a
taker well the cameras rolling around
the casino floor there's a hundred
extras right Rickles are standing next
to De Niro in a scene De Niro is acting
saying his dialogue Rickles character is
just standing there as he does for most
of the film he's not supposed to speak
and in the middle of take he'd looked at
the Dare and said sake we're gonna do it
like that no no you got the awards and
sure you know what you're doing dad and
you know every sphincter Titans on set
nobody knows how Bob as refers to Colin
was gonna react right
but Rickles knew that he owned De Niro
because De Niro worshipped Rickles and
Rickles told me this one day said early
on he said I own this guy because when
he was a kid there were two types of
pear groups on the street corners in New
York when I dinero grew up there was
doo-wop groups and put-down groups and
dinero de mierda Niro was in a put down
group your mother this your mother that
right so today I'm reckless was God and
Rickles found out about it and went
after him every day did he really
it was unbelievable it was unbelievable
yeah Wow Kevin [ __ ] you're in the
Rhode show and then another one two
grumpy old men being around lemon and
Matthau yes king of sports you know
Maddow had a very famous gambling issue
in fact that his memorial on the back of
the program were his picks for the
following Sunday are you seriously
passed
yeah Walter Matthau yeah yeah when I met
him on the set with the very first time
you never know how you're gonna meet
someone in this case it was on the set
yeah
a couple hours before we were gonna
shoot our first scene together the
director just said you know this is
kevin pollak he's gonna play her son and
then the director walked away to go
check on lights or something I'm stuck
here and ID foolishly decided to make
small talk with Walter mouthing and I
said so Walter scripts pretty good huh
and he said the scribe sock scared I owe
my bookie two million yeah he wasn't
kidding about the old man he was right
about the debt yeah lemon were my heroes
you know I grew up character actors were
my favorites I dreamt of being one and
here's to character actors who got to be
leading men and just extraordinary
iconic actors so to study at their feet
was like Mount Rushmore right you know
and then before we get to your car
project the usual suspects did you how
many times you have to read that script
before you you kind of got it how many
times at my age enough to ask me to read
it you know these were two 25 year olds
the writer the director hadn't done
anything and you know this was 1994 and
I was at a point the only two years
after a few good men where I did cross
the goal line from having to audition to
getting offers and when you're getting
offers which is rarefied air you know
you get on the phone with your agent he
says he tells you what the projects are
that are coming our way yeah and he
would tell me about this script and I
you know so the questions would be who
wrote her who's directing it who were my
co-stars because you're guilty through
association right you want to be lifted
by these entities and he kept coming
back to the usual so are these guys he
said trust me just read so I got to page
five and I called him and said I'm in no
matter what
I'm in and then Brian singer the
director
said I want Kevin in the movie I've
promised to meet with two different
actors to audition I can't not have them
come in I want Kevin to do it but I have
to let them come in an audition and I
said in my agent is this an offer or
what he says you said no it is he wants
you to do the movie but out of
obligation to the agents and what have
you you know you it's protocol you can't
not see these people I said what I can
let some age actor come in and steal my
part right tell them I'll come in and
read for an offer my agent said yeah no
you're not doing that right you know
there's there's rules to this game right
as someone who's newly at that you're
getting offers yeah don't do it Tony you
don't go in and read exactly ready it
right I didn't want to wait so I went in
and read and got the part and you got it
yeah yeah and then you know look the
movies lightning in a bottle you need to
look further than the fact that Stephen
Baldwin's great in the film right and
you know that it's a flute and I tweet
out I tweet out his his look of just
shooting you know at the at the lineup
that look he gives to the camera yes any
time the kicker Brandon McManus makes a
kick for the Denver Broncos like just
its McManus it's you know man and then
obviously Keyser söze is just it's just
a a mythical character that people
always bring up yeah so when you see the
movie it's one of the great you know
surprise endings but I'll tell you when
you read the script
it's felt more impactful because when
you're reading you're imagining
imagining this world and your page
turning it's such a page-turner as a
read that script and when you get to
that moment in the script I'm telling
you it was more shocking than than
seeing it happen in the mood for me
anyways experience and then let's finish
up with what's going on with you right
now man congratulations on the marvelous
mrs. Mayes won the lottery with this one
right is crazy Mike texted you yeah hey
man it is unbelievable yeah that's great
truly is a special show I guess you can
call it a period piece but it's also
about a woman who decides to try
stand-up comedy in the late 50s after
her husband shocks her by breaking up
with her two asking for divorce
you played the husband's father father
and I have five and and so you played
mrs. Maysles father-in-law
and actual nasal and and it is just the
the family dynamic the humor the the
concept not so unique it's amazing Kevin
thank you brother in your welcome in
season 3
they enjoyed Tony Shalhoub and my
character being pitted against each
other so much the two dads
he had the two dads that in season 3 I
can promise even greater fireworks they
they created a storyline for us that's
maddening and fantastic but yeah they
listen the it really does feel like I
won the lottery and they done the pilot
and the way Amazon does their shows they
put the pilot up on Amazon for the
audience to weigh in and help decide
what happens and they picked it up to
two seasons based on the pilot which is
unprecedented for them and the creator
of the show you know Amy
sherman-palladino her husband Dan
realized they didn't have in-laws and
the pilot so she called and said would
you please and you know what you see
that pilot that first episode is there's
a magical quality you say you could call
it a period piece of course it is
because it's set in 1958 59 and now 60
but yeah there is a a heightened
authenticity between the Wardrobe and
the music and the cinematography there's
a you know conglomeration of all these
things that are happening at the same
time and and creating with these actors
in this writing yeah it it every now and
then you get to be a part of something
this insanely magical and I'm at a point
in my life where I get to just be
grateful honestly you know in the early
days you're you you try to figure out
what's next what's next what's next and
you have to look ahead and plan your
alleged path and mm-hm and this is just
basking in one of the greatest jobs of
all time but as a comedian first who had
no formal training as an actor and kind
of bluff my way through a number of
films leading up to this point I don't
know the exact number 91 but I've done a
few movies right six of them good and
you know I was not trained to do
eight-page oners right well there's no
cutting and there's no coverage and they
love doing this on this show where the
camera just moves through
like that one great scene in Goodfellas
through the kitchen and to the seat
right so we do that all the time and I
didn't come from the theater I didn't
train to do you know the eight pages
were there's 14 moving parts and you you
cannot be the one moving part that
messes up the tape right so that has
been the most challenging the most
rewarding well it is like I said just
amazing and and your 49ers are the one
seed in the NFC heading into week 15 and
life's good for your brother it's I'm
pleased to say that and I will add this
glorious sit with you thank you sir as
part of that right back at you man thank
you man at Kevin Pollak on Twitter at
Kevin Pollak 1 2 3 on Instagram the
marvelous mrs. Mazal worth every single
second of your time season 3 premiered
just this past Friday on Amazon Prime
video check it all out and I didn't even
hit your stand-up act at all that's how
it worked everything's online go take a
look at bless it
ok oh yeah we'd even hit billions either
but that was you a great night - thank
you kevin pollak right here on the Rich
Eisen show we'll set up the rest of the
week when we come back for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app